Watch as we knit our
Prickly Pear Pullover.
I'm sure you could knit a more exciting
version of this sweater, but to keep
things simple, I knit a plain stockinette
version and one color and followed the
pattern exactly.
The sweater is knit in just 5 pieces.
Knit the back.
It's just a rectangle,
but follow the pattern.
Place the markers and
scrap off as instructed.
Knit the front.
The neck line shaping isn't hard, but plan
to knit your front on a day when you're
fresh and there aren't any distractions.
Join one shoulder.
Knit a plain rolled neck band.
Remember, we're keeping this simple.
Then join the other shoulder.
Knit the sleeves from the top down.
Try to knit both sleeves
and one knitting session.
Again, choose a day with no distractions,
so both sleeves end up the same length.
Block your sweater, find a sunny spot,
sew up the seams, and hide the ends.
And then take a photo
and share your success.